I just did the most bad-boy thing ever
okay you guys did a little bangbang
didn't you give it a little Batman a
little double-header you gotta love it
man little Eiffel Tower
oh yeah he got a lot to tell the people
he did uh-huh first up okay
your boy goes to Waffle House he gets
the two egg breakfast okay with the
cinnamon raisin toast
oh okay interesting choice but I you
know I support it and sausage gravy
smothered hash browns oh you sick [ __ ]
I'm a sicko you sick [ __ ] that's an
absolute bad boys order really a sicko
yeah I ate all that [ __ ] and it was we
should just take note that it was four
o'clock in the afternoon okay first meal
of the day yeah that down and walk all
but 20 feet into a Wendy's and get a
six-piece paisa Nuggets and a small
chocolate frost it'll desert nothing
wrong with that yeah just see nothing
wrong you can up shake it for dessert
look at the chicken nugget parfait oh
you don't have one I'm up to order the
frosty supper and then that's fine or a
separate then I'll just dunk those yeah
submerge that chicken gets in there in
that's though that's the [ __ ] that's
the darkest [ __ ] I've done in the last
24 hours it's steak chicken and ice
cream oh you did it always okay really
always Oh chicken nugget in the frosty
mana I get the fries but I don't
understand that actual chicken just
gonna manage Aries and dropping that
down on a roasted chicken and like
[ __ ] Thanksgiving dinner or what
about using let's discussing he's using
a big chunk of raw chicken to like get
the ice cream out of the tub and into
your mouth what you do is you get you
get five like Tyson chickens sticks you
know you put them over each finger and
then you just dunk those into an ice
cream yeah thing yeah grab a clump and
you just mash the whole like you just
mush it you know I'm saying five-year
old style yeah it doesn't even all get
in your mouth yeah all over your face
just get some chicken and ice cream yeah
get you some chicken ice cream chicken
it's what's for dessert
they should rename the entire [ __ ]
poultry aisle to dessert do [ __ ] as
far as I'm concerned salt & straw
flavors next month
this is beach chicken rotisserie chicken
boiled chicken chicken cordon bleu Oh
rosemary chicken yeah I get the rosemary
chicken ice cream lemon pepper now if
you're gonna judge me for dunking a
spicy nugget in a frosty let me ask you
this you like you like [ __ ] orange
chicken right
what do we say orange chicken is candy
yeah this candy yeah it's candy chicken
yeah yeah you can't hate yeah that's
true you eat orange chicken you cannot
hate that's true
ice cream at first you know I mean
[ __ ] I I mean I'll be honest with you
I had a little chicken today too
no yeah yeah chocolate you put on it and
chocolate-covered chicken is a Hershey
bar
[Music]
just [ __ ] drizzle and caramel sauce on
it do you go to Dairy Queen if you get a
rotisserie chicken you get all those
toppings on top [ __ ] sprinkles [ __ ]
yo girl and thrown down a big piece of
rotisserie chicken right in the bottom
and then just oozing yogurt over top
yogurt chicken yogurt oh my god
dude her in [ __ ] New Orleans we're at
the Cafe Du Monde
yeah getting beignets and if there's
only one thing on the menu chicken that
you can get a chicken beignets about
putting crunch berries on my [ __ ]
boiled chicken plate with white rice and
[ __ ] star sprinkles and frosting
strawberries yeah next person you know
tomorrow if you got the 9 to 5 and you
pull up in the lunchroom I want you to
bring out your boiled chicken meal prep
and then just just just take like a
[ __ ] like a shaker of sprinkles just
leave it next to your meal but never use
it but see if anyone like just does a
double take while you're eating lunch
this is like hey hey Dave what's the
string goes for for my chicken huh my
chicken Oh see you
yeah just sprinkle it's take a bite top
of the chicken the it's desert chicken
why are you looking at me you just said
you just keep pushing oh it's for my
chicken what's up what for the chicken
yeah the chicken no I heard that chicken
okay see it's pretty spring on so let me
get this straight you it's pretty right
on top right up
so you just wanna cheat on the chicken
okay yeah yeah cool man up all right
I'll see you later she get chicken
yogurt close the door you're just a
sprinkle chicken guy work putting
sprinkles on his chicken just switch it
up like every week just Dave from down
the hall it's dessert chicken okay man
sorry
you know chicken as a dessert
[Music]